Germany's agreed to take in four
children born two former fighters from
the so-called Islamic state a German
delegation is has traveled there to
receive the children three of them are
orphans and another just six months old
and seriously ill they've been living in
the alcohol camp in northeastern Syria
which holds over 70,000 women and
children it's the first time Germany has
taken in eius children other European
countries including France and Belgium
have already done so but they are still
more than a hundred children from German
parents waiting to be repatriated
okay I'm joined now by a political
correspondent Hans brand at our
parliamentary studios and with me in the
studio I have d-damn news expert on the
circle Islamic state Florian no Hoff
Thorin let me begin with you you've
traveled extensively in the area and
worked in that region you what do we
know about this repatriation that's
supposed to be happening right now well
as you said it's for children that have
being handed over to the German Foreign
Ministry for ministry officials today at
the border between Syria and Iraq two of
them are girls one of them is a boy
they're all said to be preteens and an
orphan that's six months one of the
children is six month old only she's the
child is being repatriated for health
reasons
this is said to be officials locals and
sources on the ground have told me that
this is supposed to be the first batch
of around a hundred searched German
children or children of German descent
also some men and women are also said to
be will be repatriated in the coming
months okay so they're all very
vulnerable and these four children are
in a very vulnerable condition let me
return to your hands now what has a
German government been saying about this
repatriation because if it's confirmed
it's a pretty significant move yes it
would be a significant move if it is
confirmed but in the government press
conference today the foreign boast but
for a ministry spokesperson would not
confirm that this was happening in fact
Germany has been very cagey about this
whole process all that the government
and the foreign ministry are saying is
that they are
trying to prepare the ground for the
possibility of repatriation that
includes making agreements with the
authorities in Syria and northeastern
Syria with the authorities in the
neighboring countries and obviously
trying to confirm whether these children
in fact are of German descent are of
German nationality so so far the German
authorities have not confirmed that this
has actually happened right so no
confirmation from the govern but Florent
turning to you know the Syrian Kurds
have captured lots of is fighters a
women ensuring are living in camps in
northeastern Syria why is it so
important for them to return to their
home countries that's what I'm Rita
Human Rights Watch says that at least
11,000 women and children have been
captured who used to be members or used
to be in the so-called Islamic state and
they live in desperate conditions they
live in they're exposed to malnutrition
and several children have already died
if they stay in Syria these conditions
work they will be exposed to these
conditions and there's no way of
bringing these people to justice there's
no mechanism to trial them we should
also not forget that these people are
still these adults are still highly
radicalized we live in a separate
section of the camp where it's unsafe to
go for the security personnel and if
they're allowed to stay there then they
will keep on radicalizing their children
and these children will just grow to be
the next generation of jihadists but
turning to you now Hans we've seen that
a couple of the government's Western
governments have taken back former eyes
of Fighters now we heard what Florian
said that some of these is fighters are
still very radicalized and there's a
fear that they may radicalize but there
are others who say they've given up a
terrorist agenda so why are governments
so reluctant to actually take back these
paper
well obviously the biggest problem is
the question to what extent these people
still are radicals and to what extent
one can control them once they are back
in Germany and not all of these people
can be charged in a German Court it's
not very clear what can be proven
against them in a German Court simple
membership of the Islamic state
organization obviously would also be
something that there could be accused of
and in addition to that if you get back
dozens or maybe more than a hundred of
such people the cost of
of supervising them of surveillance
we'll go into the into the dozens of
millions I think those are the thoughts
that are behind these maneuvers by the
German government to try and prevent
this from happening right Hans Brandt
diabolos political correspondent and
Florian annoy Hoff an expert on is
terrorism thank you both very much for
sharing your perspectives